I'm Tim Vandenberg and I've been
teaching for 25 years 17 years in
Hesperia California sixth grade at
Carmel elementary school and Hesperia is
a lower socioeconomic status area on
average especially among our student
population 100% of our students at this
school are on free reduced lunch the
traditional model among most schools is
just moving kids along by age whether
they've mastered the skills or not so by
the time they come to me in sixth grade
they've got so many gaps in their
learning because they haven't mastered
the skills K through five it's extremely
difficult for most teachers probably all
teachers to truly meet each kid at their
individual mastery level you're gonna
have a third of the class tracking with
you a third of the class wishing you'd
move faster and the third of the class
wishing you'd reteach that a few more
times my goals as a teacher using Khan
Academy is for my students to master as
much of the grade-level specific skills
as they can truly master the skills what
I do is I assign to each student the
whole class an entire unit for example
expressions and variables and then that
next day in class we'll have a class
lecture students take notes and their
math portfolios and we teach the skill
of expressions and variables then they
dive right into Khan Academy start the
skills in that unit and work at their
own pace and those who need extra help
they have the Khan Academy videos and
hints and I also monitor the class Rove
around and help kids whenever they need
help when students master skills on Khan
Academy they're so excited their self
pride and self confidence just just
overflows and they start to believe they
can learn it's so important in the
learning model that students find out
immediately if they are properly
grasping a skill through Khan Academy
they get that instant feedback after
every single problem is it correct or
not correct and if they didn't get it
correct they get to find out immediate
Lee from the hints exactly where they
might have misunderstood it's so
important for students in this day and
age of technology to learn to
communicate and interact interpersonally
with others by using Khan Academy to
teach students to support one another
instead of just being locked into a
computer screen they're actually
interacting with their neighbors their
friends in class they learn to interact
with others in all of life so as many
good teachers love to do they they take
their top successful students and spread
them out in the class and give them to
elbow buddies one on each side of them
I'm monitoring I'm encouraging first
students to help each other it's so much
better when students help each other
first because then they become so much
more self-sufficient self-motivated self
rewarded plus those peer helpers feel so
special as they reward their friends
with the help that they give that really
makes it possible to promote and
increase teacher to student interaction
because now the teacher is spending
their time where students really truly
need the help on thirty two or more
different levels in a class of that many
students I don't have one math class I
have thirty two math classes every
single student is working at their own
pace now I can meet students where
they're at instead of where the middle
of the class is at because the Khan
Academy grade level skills are so well
aligned with the common core standards
for math I can trust that if my students
master those skills before the state
test they will do amazingly well and
they have for years now after class I
always make sure to look at the data
progress reports on a teacher dashboard
that really helps me know who is
succeeding and who is really struggling
and needs extra help and then I set my
pace and remediation and instructional
support accordingly there is no way I
could have known to that great detail
who is really getting it and who's not
without the help of Khan
cata me yeah I love being a teacher
because I love it when kids learn to
love learning and when they love
learning they don't need me for the rest
of their life so as they grow up and
become adults pursuing their own
interests they've learned how to learn
on their own and they have a passion and
desire to